day four of the candidates in
Yekaterinburg Russia eight chess
gladiators returned to the stage to do
battle in an epic race to decide who
will challenge world champion Magnus
Carlsen Fabiano Caruana failed to make
the most of a promising position against
yond upon the Chi and Maxim viola grove
missed the crushing win in his game
without examining chris chuck leaving
him once again in a three-way tie for
first the world is watching to see which
of these chess Matadors will take the
bull by the horns round five of exciting
action coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
from Yekaterinburg Russia it is time for
the fifth round of the 2020 candidates
to determine the Challenger the world
champion Magnus Carlsen I'm out of
hundred meters here with Grand Master
yes sir Sarah won yes they're the best
day good morning everyone and welcome to
our live coverage of the 2020 candidates
tournament look they're like it's gotta
be the shoes wonderful my niece hello
everyone the first three rounds we were
treated to a lot of decisive games round
four had a lot of action and there was
two opportunities for maybe victories
but is it ended out for draws let's take
a look at the standings Alejandra of
course with the four draws things didn't
change but let's review it where they
are Maxima Sheila Graf Wong Howe and
Jana Pagliacci are the ones clinging on
to first place with two and a half
points but it's not a very solid lead
they only half a point over Alexandra
district and Fabiano karana both sitting
on 50% meanwhile Denise Gary King Lear
and aunt Carol Alex echo they're only at
minus one so one win against one of the
leaders by them will catapult them
exactly where they need to be it's a
very very tight race so far it's what we
expect from a candidate we've gotten a
lot of decisive results but nobody has
stood out as the clear front-runner just
yet not yet but let's take a look at our
format it's a 14 round double
round-robin that means that every player
gets equal amounts of whites and equal
amounts of blocks that makes the
tournament safe and it's very very
healthy otherwise I mean you get all
these diversity very fair very fair 100
minutes for the first 40 moves
50 minutes for the next 20 once you
reach me 60 you get another 15 minutes
it's a 30 second increment all
throughout the game from move one until
the end and no draw offers before blocks
40th move even after the 40th no if we
actually haven't seen too many draw
first repetitions and things like that
exactly half a million euros is the
price fun in
Tournament everybody's pursuing that
goal of being challenger however lots of
chess left in the schedule absolutely
today's round five tomorrow we'll have
round six and you can see on that
schedule those green lines represent the
rest days there will be a rest day on
Tuesday but tomorrow there's still
another game so do join us for that one
but enough of the schedule we have
breaking news and for that we have
Grandmaster Maurice Ashley Thank You
alejandro we see some exciting games in
this tournament so far and it is no
doubt we're gonna see some more and this
round here is one of them kirill iooks
nkow the bottom seed in this tournament
play against one of what we say
presumptive favorites Maxime by Sheila
gravel he got here by way of little
aborting of a tournament of the game
between of raja baath excuse me
raja baath to wear red yama decided he
would not play due to the health
concerns but now mike seemed saying look
I am super prepared and look at this
preparation absolutely incredible Kiril
got this position his pawns under attack
and remember that game couple of rounds
ago when he had the chance to sacrifice
on g6 against nip oh he said you know
what the world didn't like it when I
didn't so let's go for it let's like a
rook of course you couldn't accept it
right away because of the move Knight
takes on e6 trapping the queen but
Maxime how prepared is this guy he
instantly captured on c3 and this
stunned Carroll as he sat and thought
for 48 minutes 48 and decided to drop
Knight takes c6 on the board what a move
I mean this is visual look how many
things are hanging Queen c8 cool calm by
Maxime night check came to f8 and then
rook 286 dou take the knight that's a
sacrifice that would certainly burn as
Queen g1 check and then your rook will
hang to mate so instead he played rook
takes a6 rook takes and just as you
think well there's got to be a deadly
disco into position rook takes c2 do
your worst
no problem and after Knight a5 King too
a knight takes on e7 and it looks as
though this is the first time Maxime is
actually thinking in this game King
takes a seven looks like the natural
move but we should note it's only moved
23 and Carol has 835 eight minutes and
35 seconds left on his clock to make
another 17 moves
that's not much in a sharp position like
this one this one is really important
because if Maxime wins he'll go to +2
but there are two other players who are
looking to also go to +2 and that's
Yann upon the Chi and weighing how you
see their Yan has a three to one lead in
their matchups just a bit of an
advantage there and he has the white
pieces today and neppo got here showing
that he belongs he is indeed the number
four player and the live rankings right
now on the planet he won that first game
against Geary just in style one of the
best games of the event so far and then
a draw against rich Christian a draw
against alex anko both of those his
countrymen and then a fighting draw
against Caruana he might have been in
some trouble but when Carolina slipped
he came right back and proved why it is
that he is this strong and Napo has been
something of an enigma on the tour he's
the kind of player who never seems happy
if he wins or loses he still has the
same expression he is seemingly a type
of sceptic about chess but when he gets
to the board he is indeed a beast a
natural player he likes to play quickly
intimidate his opponents he might make
some mistakes but then he'll play
brilliant chess and he is indeed someone
to watch with his tournament another
person to watch out for is Wang Hao he
is the number seven seed in this
competition but make no bones about it
he is a top 10 player and he's proving
it in fact by defeating the number three
player on the planet ding Lauren that
has catapulted him into the top 10 his
drug ins Giri he's going to be saying
man I
could've been plus two the only I found
the right move there and then two other
drawers against Chris Chuck and against
Alex Aiko and maybe you don't know who
he is
but the top players do know he's been a
talent for many many years he's beating
all of them he's got a five-o record
against Fabiano Caruana so indeed this
is a player who can pick them up and put
them down against the elite on the
planet
if he wins it would be a surprise but it
wouldn't be a complete shocker
indeed as anything could happen in a
tournament this strong and this round
once again is keeping us on our toes
Thank You Maurice and as we see those
two pairings let's take a look at all
the pairings of course the compliments
of those are Alex hundred grit struck
playing against England in a complicated
Spanish and onigiri trying to press
against Fabiana Quran in a very very
complex lot but Yasir enough of this
let's go directly into the girls game
cos what earth is going on here
I'm hoping that you're gonna be
answering those questions for us as it
turns out the the players have reached a
position that has been seen and three
Grandmaster games remover of takes
g-forces oh well we'd known known theory
right let's doubt to this position so he
was well aware now a little bit about
psychology of Myers this is not anything
else night or right the MBL is more of
an e5 player than he is the e6 player so
we get the English move order with f2 f3
and Knight are players like MBO like to
play e5 and I have no doubt SEC hero was
actually prepared for this move so the
movie 76 might have been a bit of a
surprise for them and they blitz their
way to again this theoretically known
position excuse me for just speeding
right through and here in three previous
games black has essayed the move King
Hey which makes perfect sense cause
you're defending the pawn on g7 but this
is where MBL came with his novelty and
it's it's really sort of like a
challenging novelty you got g7 g6 and
it's pretty self-evident that hey there
are plenty of sacrifices that black has
to face remove that you look at it and
blacks saying do your worst
exactly everything's obvious here for
white but what actually works and that's
not so easy to calculate exactly that is
the tough part I mean do you play Knight
takes c6 I mean do you even play some
other positional move like a move I
don't know like Queen Jiwon preparing
sacrifices as it turns out he took a lot
of time on these sacrifices but once he
made them yeah and let's notice just
very quickly that rook g6 obviously the
rook is taboo let's just show why
exactly you take the rook and oops your
queen is checkmated that is to say your
queen is run out of squares c7 is
covered and the Queen can't escape now
so that's the end of the game and that's
the reason for the intermezzo birthday
c3 as the Queen is actually given more
free reign so now Black is thinking okay
take my rook and I can take your rook
and my queen gets a wait so can thought
for a very long time here precisely
because I think he was contemplating
Queen takes c3 and now we have to add on
this because again it seems that if you
take the rook on g6 9:36 must be
devastated exactly because it's a
discovered attack against the rook as
well as the Queen and this is curtains
but there is the intermezzo move Knight
a4 just removing the Queen from that
diagonal precisely
now if the Queen moves I don't care
let's say we just drop back for a second
now you can take the rook and well let
me just say it's a mess it's a mess it's
a mess I mean you're down a piece for
two pawns that's white yeah King on the
8th it's unsafe but it is an extra piece
it is an extra piece and well you know
white is the one who's going to have to
prove the validity of the sacrifice
therefore we saw the move Knight
x-6 now again you can't really stop and
take the night because the now you take
the rook
you've only sacrificed one piece what
one piece for no Isis two pieces for a
rug and a pawn or two and I believe two
pawns well okay so I'm good and now it's
not even a real advantage for a material
no indeed so Knight takes c6 forced
reaction Queen CA now again MVL could
have prepared all of this once he puts
so once he played the move g7 g6
yeah these sacrifices come one after
another
Shaq king over six - clever move this
for a cage six pretty much saving some
material yes you absolutely have to take
on age sex I don't see another move
exactly and then Bishop takes and now
rook takes you to it really echoes that
game that MV ah himself played with
white against Fabi where the e5 e for
the matter and f7 you had all these
discoveries but they didn't do anything
right and that's what he's saying go
ahead make your this this go do your
worst
right and again it seems that there must
be something but black stars should have
his own threats with the rook now on c2
rook takes B to my little careful cuz
route b2 and night a4 maybe even in
conjunction with Queen c2 things could
get a little bit sticky here for white
and as buck house players know the
knight directly in front of the king or
diagonally the King doesn't do very much
no no actually takes a while to ream
inuvik to actually deliver a killing
blow it can win some material it can
destroy some structures but actually
deliver a killing blow it's not so easy
not so easy
Kiril who again as Murray said at the
top of the show way down on the clock
yeah the best he could come up with was
check and takes on e7 okay it doesn't by
the way contain the threat so no choice
no choice King takes e7 now Queen a for
change for check does cover h2 I think
heroes getting ready to play Bishop d3
to boot the rook but yes because here
Maxime is thinking it seems first
very long think of the position a and
this is the head of had between them and
much of a history not at all really 1v1
game not really sure where that was it
might have even been a while ago rumor
out the tango couldn't maybe Alex thank
you always cuz there's a younger than MV
oh yeah of course of course
so Queen h4 check and we're up to date
Maurice jump in here with how do you
think what is it that MV l is looking at
yeah you don't want to know what I'm
about
okay bleeding looking at this absolutely
chaotic position with the engine and
well I need you guys I need you guys cuz
this is insane we could go do this one
by one so already we've seen sacrifice
the double sock counter sack all that's
going on we see that white is currently
down a piece for one punch it's got two
minor pieces against three he's got five
pawns so for his Bishop is hanging on e
two at the moment and potential
sacrifices as you guys mentioned on the
b2 square but this position simply has
no positional elements to sink your
teeth into you knows you're looking and
say okay so you got the weak pawn here
weak on what are you talking about this
is about Kings being attacked and
attacked and in tactics that's it
so every move has to be calculated so
it's no surprise and VL is going to a
deep thing so let's play one casual
looking move nine of six doesn't look
like necessarily the best move to play
it might get pinned but you know if you
get your Knight to d7 it's rock-solid it
looks like you should be okay
until the guy drops rook takes d6 I
don't know it like whoa another sack how
many sacrifices do you have the point
being that now if King takes on d6 now
it's white who is winning after Queen
taste winning by the way these bishops
are ready to maraud the position
particularly this one and you literally
have nothing to do remember your queen
can't come help because this rook is
hanging why it's gonna be up to pawns so
keep material counting going why it's
gonna be up to points you cannot trade
Queens and where do you hide your King
if you play King back to d7 which is the
times are hightailed out of there you
can't go to c7 remember this
is it hanging then white continues the
attack with Queen takes and now you're
in deep trouble
because you can't block and then your
next step is gonna be in the dark square
and guess who's going to come into the
party this bishop so rook takes these
six is a monster shot rook takes now
it's not over because he can say okay
fine fine fine you're right my bad let
me protect the position well now he
continues with another sacrifice yet
again rook takes on d7 now you still
can't take with the Queen remember this
rook is hanging you can't take through
the night because you're pinched so you
have to take with the King that allows
Queen takes sacking this bishop well you
just you just got two pawns again the
two bishops chasing down the King so you
might as well remove this one and after
takes King moves and now Queen check
your king can hide again the dark
squares are a problem because this
Bishop will enter the game you have to
go back to the light square and allow
upper PEC so that's one line all right
let's get out of that line and play and
send the move and six which looks like
it's solid and doing the job well this
Bishop is hanging so you think he's got
to deal with it and he just calmly plays
Bishop f4 now again this Bishop the
marauding piece black doesn't have a
piece to counter it with he's
threatening Bishop takes these six he's
threatening Queen eight seven he's doing
all kinds of nasties in the position now
there's so many moves here
I'd like you guys what I'm not just to
get in let me just show you my one move
is rook takes Beatson oh yeah going for
nine a four check and the Queen shows up
another move is you just mentioned
Knight d5 blocking the path so that
after pawn takes he can play rotates on
e two but now he's got to deal with
Queen 287 remember d6 is gonna hang so
it looks like in all the lines white
simply has compensation for this piece
I'm down to Pete's or pawn but your King
is weaker than mine and it doesn't
matter that the bishop is hanging in the
tactics bear this position out for a
white in all the lines I'm looking at
and by the way I got lots more here I
could be going it's gonna be a lecture
for the next 30 minutes
as we break down every variation it's
crazy
and what's wild to me is that Maxime is
now thinking for the first time about
really thinking in this particular
position where white is perfectly fine
if he sees all the sacrifices White's
doing well
that's scary to me for a Maxime we've
seen this before
we see the story in a niche bullet sing
against nepo he ended up losing even
though he was well in his prep we saw
Bobby blitz against England he was he
also lost the game even though he came
straight out of prep and now Maxime
deeply thinking about a position that it
was clear that he played and he had at
home are we gonna see the story
happening for a third time weird and
finally the one move that I found
attractive King e7 King e8 after Queen
h4 check yeah well well I mean Knight f6
yeah Knight f6 I walk into a pin and I
just kind of f7 f6 somehow I like that
pawn on f7 giving me a little protection
along the side so King e8 does that have
an obvious refutation rook Jiwon you can
resign I keep I'm thinking I'm playing
rook b2 and night a4 whoa no you're
desperate yeah yeah yeah 94 check looks
good King moves yeah now you got to play
a check now nice end of checks stories
done rook c8 is coming and you've given
away your rope now so you're lying down
material and you don't have enough right
so rook g1 was this one is Chris black
he did finally play the move f6 did have
this on the board f6 f6 you were
mentioning the move Bishop f4 which
definitely looks tempting I look at
Bishop before and that's one of the
first music moves I'm analyzing but is
there an alternative there Bishop f4 the
altar yes and it's worse the move Bishop
to d2 and
seems very natural to me I've never
really considered the mole Bishop d2
actually is is a straight point your
Bishop is hanging on t2 and you clear
the line for your queen right right and
stop rugby two ideas are done so it's
actually maybe not a natural move but
has a lot of sense to it because it
saves everything for the moment you're
actually still you still keep your pawn
and you hope to get some kind of Bishop
before action later but in the meantime
you get your own threats so this move is
not completely untoward it seems like a
decent enough alternative if he doesn't
find the very sharp Bishop before Bishop
enter for you playing but you better
know that rook takes on b2 doesn't work
by the way I'm glad they played it so I
can introduce another variation rook
takes King takes the move Knight to a4
with check King b1 Knight c3 same line
we're in now if you play now you realize
the rook is actually hanging exactly all
right so this piece will drops away of
the Lion King bee 291 check Bishop takes
on D once but I could have forced a
drawer just not a full right yes you
could have sorry if if we're here King
bee - you could go back you could go
back and say I don't want to play
anymore that's right
so that is possible so Bishop f4 if he
plays it allows the game allows it from
black standpoint to just be able to play
it or takes b2 so actually if you want
Bishop f4 and he has played it he
doesn't have much time if he wanted to
get more out of the position like dare
his opponent he could play Bishop g2
that would be the moment to say let's
keep going let's see if this position
has more in it because after Bishop to
t2 the move the engines giving is 95 but
duck and just do like black here so this
would be a risk it is the poor it's a
piece after all
so although the line Queen h7 check has
to be met by 9 f7 and look at this one
he 5 that's cute b5 well c2 is hang c2
is hanging to - a queen and you're gonna
break up the position service so this
could have gone extremely wild he might
consider this if he had another hour on
the clock mm-hmm but I still don't like
it even with the movie 5 yeah it's still
it's still a little bit better for white
after rook takes four vacuuming from I'm
sorry after rook takes on d2 but you
gotta admit guys this is worth a punch I
mean this is a Wow we're going for if
you could get this move in
so Bishop f4 he's now playing natural
moves with a clock giving him so much
pressure he's just trying to play
natural moves let's just keep playing
natural moves and Bishop f4 certainly is
one of those moves that catches your eye
very aggressive threatens a big threat
and tells the guy well if you want to
draw then go for it
but I'm ok with that given that my clock
is in such a bad state and I am assuming
it is a draw I had another question
since you do have the engine after
Knight a for check-in I go king a1 or is
gonna be a drawing dates here 94 check
not now
no no after he 93 here here and King
anyone the thing is that d6 is is
protected so here white does have to go
for this prepare my kaftan I cannot just
take the knight Bishop takes on d1 is
also playable that does allow this Queen
to enter on a couple of squares but this
one being one it's even material but I
would think yeah that King doesn't seem
a 3s hanging this Bishop is dropping to
like I 110 put too slow yeah you would
you wouldn't be surprised if there was a
perpetual there for black well let's
just go from explosiveness and calm calm
our beating hearts to the matchup
between our two tournament leaders
coming into the round yes
yon and winning how boy talk about a
sedate game let me just take it from the
very very top because it's going to go
very fast it's it strikes me that so
much of this was well I want to say
theory the Petroff very very tough
defense for white to crack in fact is to
get play against the petrov has been
very difficult a more tame line with
night
- yeah 93 being one of the main lines
trying to very quickly organize things
on the kingside yes and it opens up the
B file which tactically can be important
there are some route you want ideas that
they're not so trivially met you don't
really want to play b6 you don't want to
put your Queen depending upon exactly he
didn't try that though yan just played
ninety-two and it seemed after ninety
six blacks you slowly slowly but did
neutralize this early initiative by the
way I should just point out that right
here the this was a novel move and not
according to our database it hasn't been
considered it does seem very natural
gives g5 the squared to the white pieces
h5 h6 may be an idea obviously the pawns
taboo right with the knight on d6
hanging don't don't don't grab the pawn
you'll get spanked Knight back and then
very quickly well I don't know it just
feels like especially after Bishop d6
that black is should be very very
satisfied he just traded off everything
I was very surprised because I was also
I was getting ready for the show today
yes now sizing this position after
before the move chief for I think after
Knight takes EAD and I thought okay I
thought the same as you that this should
be completely satisfactory for the black
pieces right you got everything off the
board fallen structure the computer was
giving just clear wide advantage
what clear right not even a little bit
like clear wide and I think I'd involved
the move h6 just putting cementing this
idea before g4 and I think playing eight
h6 directly I thought that it was the
problem was there was a pin right yeah I
don't remember if it was in this
position specific here before and there
was some queen a3 idea get you out of
the pin that's nice okay was so easy and
then we talked about the alpha 0 pond on
h6 and we saw that in the game of yeah a
B but over to you
Maurice you've got some breaking news
for us I just want your thoughts on a
position as this position obviously is
the game of the round rooked it's be to
check King be 294 King be 193 yes King a
one sidestepping and we play this move
Knight takes do you want right in this
position okay
maxime has to calculate now right
because you mentioned bishop takes me
one queen c5 why can't really go for
this position but if he throws in queen
8 7 check okay where do you put your
king let's assume e6 for just a moment
alright now if you put my choice right I
can't go this is the question okay so we
have to quest King d8 is one line a
queen g8 King back to e7 trade and play
this endgame it's an extra pawn it's a
it's a outside part of two bishops the
agents say equal here equal but how do
you feel I like the two bishops and this
guy's always on the board I think the
engine is misjudging this I even if it's
judging it right nobody's gonna want to
play this in you are blind right because
you could just see why it's never gonna
lose yeah and black could easily lose so
so this this position is the one I was
looking at I said hold on which means if
Queen eight seven check King e6 looks
more like the try but now he can take on
d1 and this Queen c5 idea
you got a Bishop b3 coming just check
don't forget you got a queen g8 idea
coming as well
is this a position you want to play over
that endgame well these are your two
choices if I look at Queen c3 check and
right I can follow it up with Knight c5
I'm not particularly scared as block
okay well c5 it stops Bishop b3 check
you got a check on the back row yeah
this is the kind of position I'm not
that scared because once my Knights will
see five bishops always defend that you
would have to hit my king on my d6 point
at the same time for me to actually be
and that's what happe well that's what
he that's what he's after
as now this check okay King back to e6
and now you can resign Oh
you have no threat you have zero threats
you're guarding everything now then dc-6
is hanging this square is hanging you
have to be precise you actually in this
position after Queen g7 check
you must go straight back only move
giving away your pawn the point being
that Bishop d6 is actually met by the
winning Queens III check gotcha so yes
you're right you are okay but you have
to calculate and I think he has to
calculate from back here
yeah cuz Quidditch four on the board
this one you have to calculate from this
position right and go straight down into
this line and say okay when I get there
my king is safe on e6 there are no
problems I play Queen c3 Knight c5 and
then after his checks my king is safe on
eight come on that's not easy some
accurate and we're going down one line
he has to go through everything he has
to check every every every every that
there's no challenges at all this could
eat up a lot of clock time and that's
why he's thinking right now so by no
means is Maxim out of the woods in this
position well luckily he has a lot of he
has a lot of time to cogitate over it
whereas opponent doesn't by the way
anybody would like to join our show we
do have a telephone number Alejandro
your call please call us at three one
four three six one five four six five
we'll be thinking any chest slash
candidates related questions yes we have
we encourage it to keep on calling
really keeping us on our toes now when
we left it I just wanted to go back to
the game of a nap oh and Wayne how here
because you had said that you're coming
into the studio writing of the game and
the computer was suggesting H saying it
wasn't in this position I just don't
remember exactly when it was but it was
this idea of putting the pawn on h6 and
escaping this pin yes with a move Queen
a3 because after the move Queen a three
row row
we are threatening checkmate in one and
one movement after King g8 I'm assuming
the knight is going somewhere yeah
probably the reason it wasn't in this
in specific right and then just thought
it was better just happy to have the
pond on h6 yeah whereas I think a lot of
human players there's just kind of a
little reluctant especially an endgame
right kind of thought this is a good pun
in the middle games no I was brought up
and in the end game we just kind of
Falls yeah yeah you have to be careful
that it doesn't get swooped up that was
not what Yan did Yan play g4 a 7 a 6 and
see the subtlety of a 6 right right that
weakness against the double attack yes
side step being a move like Queen a3
with that double attack that you just
mentioned g4 a6
now after b3 Queenie 693 I gotta tell
you this is a draw this is just like
it's anything and I'm back over to you
Maurice a position that does feel like
something though is the game between a
niche giri and Fabiano Caruana america's
best looks like he is in some real
trouble in this game after he started
the opening and it was an imbalance
position as you could see the formation
is quite in balance White has the two
bishops and when you have the two
bishops it's not about your bishop that
matches your opponent's it's about the
other one and this light square bishop
is lurking it's looking for the day when
it can create some problems and we're
gonna see create problems after b3
dealing with the one threat block had on
this line 9 h5 and he said no we're
gonna try to lift this blockading piece
g6 was played trade trade and now f4
this King cannot get out of the center
so easily he's of course not interested
in see pawns especially since his own
King is on the trouble King f8 trying to
Castle by hand and what did we say about
this LightSquared bishop here it comes
Bishop to e2 rook to h8 and now Bishop
to d3 they just wanted to play more
directly with that v before but this is
also quite strong the threat is f5 below
open this castle to King position and if
that happens his King will be perfectly
safe
but this King is gonna face a barrage of
white pieces this is difficult to defend
guys this looks like problems for Fabi
at the moment he's also down on the
clock yet to make 14 moves and seeing
his King under threat the worst part
about this situation is he really
doesn't have any counter play there's
you look over there you say what's black
doing Black has nothing
to write home about like just literally
has no attacking plans c5 would be the
only way to try to drum up something but
that probably helps white by opening up
the game in the meantime you're facing
what looks like a very straightforward
attack I'll just play at five and even
if it doesn't work it just makes perfect
sense Bobby would be in deep trouble
their lifetime scores is dead even
Gary's not afraid of Caruana
as you can see there and this last move
this position I gotta say I'm not liking
how Ana's positioning at all 31 duel
between them these two players were
really taking the measure of one another
that's an amazing number that's more
games than I've played against any other
player I think I have like 25 games with
Tim on that's 30 games yeah wow they
really really are familiar with this
looks really bad but yes you have to
take a look at Alex and cos game because
it's moving so quickly okay and it's
such a weird position I know it is
really good so we are going down the
path and Maurice has been explaining to
us after Bishop f4 f6 shame for me to
was played okay
the best defense is a strong offense I
guess certainly no other move by taking
the exactly Knight a four check and you
want no real other squares for the
unites III check played and now he's
deciding between King a1 and I'm King b2
and I don't see any other move hiking a1
by the way I would have played King b2
one time just to ask my opponent are you
interested in making a draw well there's
this check that we had mentioned and on
King a one night takes d1 that's that's
check on the King on b2 which means that
the variations could have been different
yes absolutely yeah check and then move
the Queen somewhere and then move the
Queen's I'm not see what we're insisting
that this is okay for you yeah so here
perhaps wants to play King a one and
force this line of knight takes they
wanted in Queen age salad all right
let's take a look King a one Knight
takes to you I'm also assuming that this
is forced right and well otherwise why
did you sacrifice your rook nah doesn't
do you want and now this is where you're
saying you've got to
a move Queen age you know seven check
and then we got to that and I was
looking at the endgame the more I looked
at the idea the more Murray's put it up
the less I thought it was dangerous for
black after Queen GA yeah Queen GA King
e7 and you take on CA you take on CA the
this was where the engine said even and
we all went well yeah maybe not so much
even to to bishops and a passer yeah but
then I started looking and I thought if
you start playing move like 95 bringing
your night to nice central right my idea
is really simple I'm gonna go Bishop e6
d5 I'm gonna break up those pawns mm-hmm
and at that point that you probably
happy very utilizing very happy I think
I've equalized
okay so let's assume I've got to move my
Bishop play yeah but that knight on e5
bothers me it's a start it's a sorry g3
you preferred Bishop G you stay out of
range of that stupid night a 93 I was
looking at the same thing 93 could
bother a bishop on c1 but okay Bishop e6
or it should be seven actually I like we
should be sin a little bit more because
I have t5 an f5 now that you okay right
f4 now Knight c4 is a double attack
right d5 is my next move this rook looks
extremely Jewish to me
fair enough the more I loved at it we
have a caller
absolutely we have one color from taxes
please give us your name on your
question yeah hi
yes they're in Alejandro this and
Maurice this is Rory from Texas and Mike
yeah and my question is really old-timer
yes sir
you remember when Fischer was on the
candidate we all knew the way he was
destroying everybody and that he was
going to win the World Championship and
beat Spassky
but from what I'm seeing here I don't
see any one of these players was gonna
beat Magnus what do you think about this
Roy that's a great question because I
mean it was like the rising star
Bobby Fischer well you could see him
coming from a mile away
Oh rising star by
one garry kasparov man Karpov could see
him coming a mile away
Vichy and not you know he could see
Magnus call away
who's Magnus worried about kind of a
different stage of World Championship
and that this is the world champion just
dominating right and I think this is
kind of when they were candidates or the
or the likes to face Gary
mm I mean nobody really saw anybody
beating Gary right and we're in a
similar situation there are people in
this room that can beat Mike very very
challenging no question I mean you saw
Fabi it really came out in London
moments and even Sergey I mean yes
Sergey acquitted himself marvelously
well I felt yeah so you won't see
anything where you think the Challenger
is gonna dominate exact I think when we
saw that Carlsen a non match that was
such an exception in the world of chess
I mean Carlsen came as such to such a
clear favorite I don't have had a bad
year cause I had a great year right so
much pressure at Vichy yeah but nowadays
with Carlsen being so solidly cemented a
number one yeah it's tough to see
somebody just rise up out of nowhere
right prior to the tournament Rory we
have all the experts felt at least that
the two players most likely to give
Magnus the the best hustle word Engler
in and Fabiano car you wanna I still
think that's the case but you making a
good point in the sense that whoever the
Challenger is he's not coming out of
this tournament as thus far I mean keep
in mind four rounds of play with you
know like this combat streaking across
the sky
watch out one Magnus Carlsen your your
time is up no I agree I agree you look
at you look at history usually the best
usually the Challenger when he's coming
the just everybody's looking at is going
to say that's the guy that's the guy
that's the guy we could see it that's
the one who's a chump you almost don't
even need to play the man all those
candidates though that's the guy when
Smith's law challenge Botvinnik he
was the guy I mean that's just clear he
was the man he he went through both
candidates Zurich he went through to get
there and proved I'm the guy he went to
any tide Botvinnik in the first match he
went to Amsterdam he did it again
that stopped me beat valve in ik for the
world title of anything came and beat
him and then who showed up in 1959 in
Yugoslavia the meteoric top I mean the
rise was just unbelievable and he ran
away with that Tournament point a half
ahead of his nearest rivals and then he
went on and smacked by Vinick my minute
came smacked him back but it's pretty
clear that's the guy Fischer showed up
that's the guy and as you guys have
already mentioned Kasparov I've showed
up it's like that's right now anyway
chronic what I mean sorry not crumbling
but uh Carlson won yeah we all knew
who's the number one player in the world
yes just a matter of time right now
Carlson is still the number one player
in the world
I actually think in some ways in order
to be the Challenger you almost have to
be the number one rated guy if you're
gonna be the new world champion I think
you actually have to take over and
rating before people say well you're
gonna beat this guy you're definitely
the new one I don't think you can be
under the the champion I think you have
to be either over his rating or
approaching especially if you have a
busy world champion as Carlson is he's
extremely busy it's not like remember
the days when Anand for example was
number one and everyone was saying all
but he's not playing enough tournaments
he's not winning in our tournaments and
people were critiquing that he continued
to win the world championship titles
well then this Magnus Carlsen showed up
and said I'm winning everything
including whatever he's in I'm the
dominant player so clearly I'm the one
who should be world champion and it took
him some time in a precarious here that
it's in 2013 where he only got through
by tie bank but since then he has proven
I am the great king of chess and I may
end up becoming one of the best maybe
I'm the best player of all time he's got
a ways to go still but he is definitely
in the argument right now nobody except
Fabi is close to him in rating so we'd
say Fabio
be the best Challenger it says he's
already proven but his Fabi the guy not
clear yet well you made an interesting
point there I must say that was like 20
years at Gary's Varro was number one but
there was like this briefest of moments
there was like one rating list that
Vladimir Kramnik was like two rating
rights just like and you said oh [ __ ]
I'm a challenger and guess what in the
year 2000 Vladimir did pull off an upset
it's a great point you'd that moment
where you're the number one player in
the world I don't think that any moment
since Carlson got that has anybody
thought oh this one has a chance Fabi
that moment in 2014 you ride from the
Sinquefield Cup right seven so close yes
number two almost almost there
I remember at the world championship
match it was points away
yes or something like that in the rating
difference right so very very tight for
sure and I think that's the rivalry
right now mm-hmm
but if I was playing the way he's doing
this candidates and let's take a look
let's take a look at how he's doing yeah
because why not really happy about today
in fact sorry folks you we were in
studio earlier we then come on but we
were following this game closely and we
were very critical early these players
to be honest yeah well g5 in particular
really had us kind of like what is fabbi
doing with the move chief
I mean this he's just let's go back just
for a moment he just played the move
Knight b6 perf okay c5 so that he has a
little bit of a tickle with B 6 and then
we Queen b8 that looked like a little
strange
then g5 you know like we're really
banging the drum for b6 here g5 and even
here this is where we really embraced a
Nisha's position we liked unease just
going for a pawn sacrifice like this
where we just thought that a bee would
be on the back foot
yeah once I saw a 45 it's such a common
motif in this structure specifically
this looks terrible
the more we analyze it because you
wanted to make a natural move for the
Queen c7 for example that's long castle
get that King out of there easy-peasy
elusive and in a beautiful fashion too
because after this takes takes stop here
and think for just a second you you
really want to play Knight g3 I mean
that's a beautiful pin you're gonna bomb
and let's win that pawn back but then
you think about something else you
suddenly your eye is drawn to the move
Knight f4 why because the knight is
attacking the knight you go pawn here
and then comes the sacrifice and it just
explodes the position is destroyed but
we have some breaking news from the
every L gained Maurice yes it does look
as though we have a repetition occurring
Queen h7 check King d8 Queen GA check
King to e7 Queen 87 check k d8 Queen GA
King c7 and Queen h7 check and the game
has ended a wild draw it is now official
what a game that usually happens in
these explosive positions that they end
in draws and both players I don't know
what they'll be thinking it looks like
maxime got the kind of position he would
want and he proved once again the night
off is impregnable I can play it all day
for a draw if I want to and you can't
slip up but Kirill acquitting himself
quite well in a position he did not know
and manage yet again to Troy so only a
minus one after five rounds guys the
youngster is proving he's proving a lot
he really is he's doing very well in
this tournament so far we have a caller
from Pittsburgh hello can you give us
your name on your question hi yeah I'm
Jason so I you know if I'm if I'm seeing
these games correctly this is the first
game that we've had a Sicilian and I
find this really surprising because no
matter what database you look at going
far back as you know as far as you like
the Sicilian just objectively scores
better than the ROI or the petrov and i
realize while the Petroff and the roy
give greater draw
chances shouldn't you simply play the
opening with the with the best expected
score which is the Sicilian first of all
I hadn't even realized that was the
first 'silly
it is the facility I think that is
really a surprise because the color is
absolutely right that in fact the
Sicilian is one of the most popular
defenses we've seen Berlin's already in
the tournament yes but the Sicilian and
oh don't you objectively just go for
what gives you the best chances oh yes
when open we're making an opening
repertoire this there's a column on
chess base that gives you the percentage
was impersonation yes the higher I go in
the chess world the more I realized that
if there was a possibility to grab a
torch and burn that statistic you just
burn it it is really worthless it's
misleading it's extremely misleading it
doesn't account for risk factors it
doesn't account for rating differences
it doesn't account for so many
statistics that are also important and
at the same time irrelevant because
there are some lines which are
immediately discarded because they have
an 80% win rate for white Wow and you
look at the line and it's just that
black didn't find the defense right they
kept falling for the same thing but had
they known it the game is just a draw so
okay this happens very often in a lot of
openings and you will see very rarely
that 2800 so look at that they're better
than these players why do I care how
they score right right it's about my
games and the Sicilian is made in such a
way that it's just higher risk factor we
talked about this earlier in the in the
broadcast that high risk doesn't
necessarily mean that much higher reward
and in this case with the black piece is
very often you just want to go for solid
straight you want to know what's going
on you don't want to fall for
preparations now the fact that we
haven't had that many system that's a
bit of a coincidence we do have a couple
of Sicilian players we have net boss
tonight or player Grichuk play Schneider
sometimes but he's been playing burly
and exclusively MVL right so you just
probably have to wait a little bit for
nappa to get blocking us an e4 player I
mean nipple playing white against Maxime
probably will also be some kind of
Sicilian please play the Sicilians to
jump it right in here Maurice you love
your Sicilian absolutely and I again I
agree it's just who's playing in the
torn
yeah it's not about whether or not the
Sicilian is good or is it bad
people have their repertoires and their
players who decide I am NOT a Sicilian
player I don't care if it is a decent
opening or great opening so to speak
statistically it's sharp it's risky
there's a lot of work involved and I got
other stuff that's good and and that's
the stuff I'd rather play and it makes
sense for them and it's gotten them to
where they are in the world right now
which is pretty high up so yes I don't
want them bothering my Sicilian by the
way talking about neppo as a Sicilian
player he doesn't like dead positions
and you might say not so great for him
maybe but guess what see for time to
sack upon which you dare not take this
point in eight six we start this alpha
zero pawn on eight six this King is
feeling a little bit of air restriction
that is and it takes which did happen
takes don't grab this one you're gonna
get spanked Queen takes and now the
simple Queen - H - by the way H - very
critical take technically now is point
is he's gonna be threatening to come
down into the position and there's
nothing to do you're literally have
nothing to do you're busted you cannot
come back home and help things are gonna
drop in the position the beat ball is
gonna drop or this f6 pawn I'll give you
a line if you come all the way back
Queen to d6 this one is gonna be sugar
because now you have to guard it Queen
to f7 and that only allows this check
and sorry you're going to get mated so
big big problems in this position so
that's why he did not touch the pony
play the move King to g8 and now the
engines are giving Queen g3 and saying
now you're gonna get squeezed the threat
of c5 Queen coming in in fact this looks
like a mistake in the position but
apparently not so bad after King of
seventh you know this reminds me of the
game between Fabio netball from last
round yeah right it was the Queen and
actually a lot of the features was Queen
a million there was Queen a knight but
there was a past deep on
for white which could happen here was
the move d5 right just the miners are
different obviously and the defense was
bring the King to the center of the
board and here comes that Katie say I
gotta get out of that corner so very
similar features to yesterday's game
this time of course was nepo with the
white pieces yeah echoes yesterday
question how that looks like a quick
look at the standings as we do have one
draw already Maxine michela graph jumps
to three points he's occur in leader we
probably expect them to at least be
caught by a walk he will definitely be
at least caught by one of the players as
he honest of course playing wrong how
exactly and if that Fenderson a draw
then again we'll have a three-way tie at
least depending on the results of the
other games which reminds us how is
Chris Chuck doing anything there is
indeed that game has not caught our eye
at all I'm sorry to say it's been a very
solid affair I'll just come up to the
current position and as you are about to
see the players are in a three versus
three Black has a slightly worse
structure after Queen g4r up d8 Bishop
III three versus three all on the Kings
side yes you can make the argument that
the pawn on e5 is a slightly weak pawn
put it on f6 it's a dead draw White's
slightly better but this has 99 percent
drawing chances written all over it I'm
afraid even if you do win that part I
was gonna say which end game wins which
one which one is the only one it looks
like that wins maybe a bishop and know
the business of that drug if you can get
me to trade off this pawn and you get me
to trade off everything on that square
the problem is I'm gonna trade a couple
of things but I'm gonna keep something
one and and most likely I'm gonna keep
the rook right right I'll get I'll trade
Bishop a queen upon but I'm not going to
the King upon anything that one you can
forget about but if I can keep a piece
on the board when we're all said and
done right you're not gonna win this
agreed worries Alejandra we have another
color this one from New York awesome
well hello New York to us your question
our harrowing movie just show New York a
daunting good I got a question for you
about I basically it's about Wesley so
and Nakamura I remember so well Nakamura
for while they were in the top being or
the top 10 plays in the world and they
were winning a lot of tournaments
doesn't seem like so went to one of
those where I'll just take a paycheck
and draw and he hasn't been in the same
place do you think it's possible that
these guys maybe started too young and
chest and they get tired of playing or
the money is just better where if you
fission second it's as much as finishing
in the first points because they don't
seem to be playing with the same desire
to pay one side I just want to get your
cleaner charlie with a little smack down
on Wesley rose to number two in the
world but let's face it he has faded a
bit he has not been performing with that
same Wesley so when we remember the year
is a million dollar open Maurice and
just everything it was amazing jump in
here with answer Charlie's question for
Charlie has he become too satisfied
Frawley it's rough at the time you can
search but to maintain consistency is
extremely difficult even the year froggy
surge in 1/7 went looked 7 in a row in
the sink filled cup look like he was the
main challenger he took a step backwards
big step backwards when Fabi actually
won the candidates he was the number
five seed in that tournament it doesn't
matter it's hard at the top to tell it
to Levon Aronian he was number two in
the world and couldn't win the
candidates couldn't win at regular
tournaments
finally started winning again why
because the company their wolves in
there these guys are wolves sharks they
bring out the knives they are hungry
they want to come after you to maintain
consistency at that level is a sign of
true
in the one person who has done that is
the world champion Megan and the main
problem that these top four players face
is Magnus you can win tournaments yes
congratulations
but when Magnus shows up misses like he
did last year at the beginning of the
year I think I'm gonna win seven in a
row or maybe we ain't right he said I'm
just gonna start winning everything my
form is back here I come even Magnus was
inconsistent for a while remember a year
and a half went by without Magnus
winning a super tournament exactly
that's insane Magnus you could have said
well Magnus has fallen off until he came
back and said no I haven't you know I
was in a little bit of a hiatus but I
fixed my game everybody goes through it
but to keep winning at the highest level
especially with the presence of a
dominant world champion you know you
just get tired in there there's so many
hungry players so I I wouldn't say they
started too young or that they faded I
just think it's rough for the topper to
maintain that kind of consistency is
extraordinarily difficult its nature at
least especially for a lot of people
like ours specifically with that example
us we do have the ratings from the
tournament these are the ratings before
determined and this is the updated
version yeah three four five six Dean
Lawrence slipping out of the twenty
eight hundred club there just by a bit
how is the jumping into the top ten
Geary started top ten is now 13 not a
huge differences of course one of those
was on the outside looking in on the top
ten right one of the big misses that say
of the candidates Wesley so it's not
there another one of those top ten
players right but I was talking about he
carves specifically yes please Hikaru is
one of those people that he's an
unbelievably talented chess player I
promise he's a really smart guy and many
other things and so many others
distracted he's distracted he said he's
a very successful streamer he has his
investments and I know that he's really
into the stock market as well as real
estate in Florida over the guy the guys
is climbing Peaks
like what you know he contributes to
causes as I understand through his
physical athleticism which you would
expect from a chess player
so yeah variety one of the car was main
issues is sim just being distracted by
so many different things but a lot of
times you wouldn't even be that strong
unless there are certain players like
that who would be that strong unless
something else was feeding them feeding
their intellectuality their physicality
it's just something else because just
focusing on chess they'd burn out they
burn out a lot sooner they're just not
that interested Murray's fabi's played a
move that I wouldn't have considered had
my life depended on it like wow I mean
that's you're saying a lot there he's
played a move he's done default yeah he
started with secret that was the
reaction I had for you is that correct
six ending okay so yes a great defense
with Bishop f6 we're holding on I'm
assuming I don't like that light ball I
don't like that white bar but it worse
is Bishop Bishop to be fine so I have to
take on I don't want to but I had think
I have to take on g4 well I didn't think
you wanted to take on d4 initially so I
guess all right and I've got now you
have to be Knight f6 and defend this
there's so many threats with rook a four
on tap I don't think you're gonna take
on f5 and take on a two because that's
not happening but I am going to play
rook to a5 stopping the attack deadly
yeah pardon me rook a four to stop the
attack down the a file and by the way
blacks King is suddenly the attention of
White's affections why would you take on
d4 and Maurice jump in here I think the
move c5 was okay but I was expecting
Bishop F saying that's all that it's all
been all bad see if I was necessary
Seifer well you didn't even like c5 I
did in real I didn't see why you were
opening up that well well first of all
what are you supposed to do I'm not
happy with my position but if somebody
gave me this position okay told me you
must defend yes I start thinking mine
item d7 needs a better square agree
let's just put it on f6 to begin with I
still have f5 g5 for the moment I I'm
hoping I'm not dying immediately ugly my
money after Bishop g3 you might be dying
immediately I'm not happy about I'll
play g4 I'll say you know if you take on
f6 you have opposite color bishops you
won't check my me so easily I'm not
happy I'm not saying and I think you
know you know it was like one of the
funniest things was our very first world
champion Wilhelm steinitz he was like a
cantankerous guy he would like I'm going
to fend the most ugly position you've
ever seen you like dude you're the world
champion why are you playing this
rubbish I mean this horrible stuff I
mean this is a position where you're not
saying hey I'm so happy to be blocked no
I mean you're suffering I'm suffering
but I look at the position this is the
way you think black should have to
suffer like yes but whereas you think
when you see a move like c5 well c5
strong helping my opponent it's
structurally bad right because it D
drive is now undefended well not only
that you yes what I was trying to play
against right this Bishop on a1 is
really kind of a septic piece and when
you please is it play the most c5 in you
allowed Bishop c3 you start to think is
white hey my bishop might be an all-star
barely not thinking it's so bad for
black so I want to trade this is bad
okay but okay it had fabby played the
move Bishop f6 and not taking on d4
what's the killer probably think f55
mercilessly at all yeah it just opens to
my ear
you're still shaking and oh my gosh okay
good good look at the game look what
happened in the game he didn't find
Bishop to b5
but what he found was plenty good as
well it goes in the game he did take on
f6 yeah just go back a couple of matter
now right this was it he just took okay
would you play to five which looks
really strong I mean be king again new
please he is not your joy it's night
please do not anybody Tommy White's
better I am I'll take one f5 oh yeah
I'll take on that five phone you I
assume you take on that five here right
[Music]
yes
let's assume you're right all right and
now I want to get my Queen to d6 somehow
how do I get it there
this Queen I need yes my queen to do
something useful maybe Queen 83 maybe
Queen c7 you wanted to get the Queen
looks so delicious man if somebody tells
me this is what we're trying to do for
black yeah yeah cuz I want to put my
Queen on d6 and somehow hold on to this
position okay your threats for now are a
little bit vague okay so let's try I
just did you just put a moving on a move
on the board and Maurice is saying look
I'm gonna play rook f1 yeah I'm playing
for Bishop e6 I'm playing for go ahead
put your queen wherever your queen wants
to go alright can I start playing Queen
c5 Queen c5 let's say I'm not with the
floor when do I want to put tray Queens
when 95 I was about to play Bishop c4
but maybe that's exciting there oh he's
alright d4 bishop is a very much better
and b5 has been told has been played by
Fabi not this variation Wow okay let's
just do I
that's that's a move really really what
we're trying to do is get into the mind
of fab' what on earth is that move doing
if you put a rock on f1 now okay I think
that has that this six was a problem
because a to say no no roti f1 Queen D
for Queen c6 threatens Queen D society
that I'm sorry okay so in this position
regime later at the f1 okay you wanted
to play Queen Queen Queen D for just to
throw it on the board we see six I think
I'm throw any Queen d6 check and I
probably check made yeah and I think I'm
turning it rook like okay you're you're
you're you you're hitting some sweet
spots here and I don't like it
Alejandro this is a good time to turn
their attention away and take a phone
call
oh yes please hello caller and welcome
to our show your name and where you're
calling from please hi my name is Rob
and calling from New Jersey hi Rob hi
so just want to follow up on the
previous callers question we're looking
at 20/20 now but let's look ahead to the
2022 candidates tournament think of
up-and-coming players these days will be
the top seeds or real contenders and
that will be Ali razor or that young
Grandmaster from India I'll hang up and
listen well thank you for the question
2022 looking ahead we still got 2020 to
deal with but I must say that for Rouge
oh wow he's really you could be that guy
right anybody else that you're well the
India it's not just like this one player
from India it's like kind of a weird
situation for a lot of them because
they're very talented but right now
they're only 2600 we're not talking
about the jump from 26 to 27 we're
talking about be 27 for a year
qualify to the candidates and I want to
do 28 yeah do it do it in the Grand Prix
series right yeah yeah it seems
difficult to me to believe very hard
those players will do other yeah he's
already 27 plus expect them to become
yeah you expect that guy to be in the
2022 the others the others I feel 2024
it's a better mark for them they're
still very young people like deuce Becky
grandmasters there were like 14 15 right
now you know give them another four
years of preparation I think in - I
don't see them reaching a candidates -
names quickly for your wayi and Duda
yes where do you do that very powerful
players can they make that jump because
Wendy we've been talking about him like
ali reza yeah wakey wakey wakey for
years years and years right and he stay
27 20 which is great which is great
strong player nobody's saying that but
he's he candidate level hmm that's not
yet not yet but when but when what way
so so to me I mean the caller answered
his own question you clearly know enough
about the world of chess to know what's
up and it's a Larissa I mean that's the
guy that's the one that we're saying can
he make that jump and get into the top
10 his talent level is extraordinary his
play is refreshing
I'd love to watch the kind of chaotic
positions he gets into he needs a few
super tournaments and I'm sure it's a
bad time in the world for a player like
that who would love to play five or six
invitationals where he can cut his teeth
against the best players and see what he
needs to do to be solid enough while
also using his new creative style that
fresh air
so we could say yeah I actually do
belong with these guys and it's my turn
to challenge Magnus this this would be
this will be a great time for him but
unfortunately you know we may see some
curtailing of chess events we've already
seen it in the world to give him that
opportunity so 2022 might even be
further away just because of that
reality alone and it may be the top
players who we see now will maintain
their status but I see him I just he's
like a meteor flashing across the sky
when Fischer won that great game against
Bern yeah game of the century the
Russians all went that's the guy watch
out he's gonna be tough and then he went
you know he was invited to all those big
tournaments tal put a little spanking on
him right in Yugoslavia beat him for Oh
but they knew he was coming and even
then it's a Fischer a while to even get
into the question it's a 1972 59 when he
when he showed up in the intro zonals
and it was 72 when he finally won so
well remember those were the years of
the three-year cycle of it that's
another new Jeffrey's young Americans
Geoffrey Jean how do you feel about
Geoffrey me personally yeah Geoffrey's
talent yeah but he's not quite there yet
as far as I'm concerned he's showing
ridiculous I'm saying the guy in terms
of Magnus Fabi Geoffrey's right there
he just needs a little bit of a boost
judges the other kind of player that I
think for years exactly but I think it's
more a little bit more time as he gets
more something is that there's a little
something actually you got to wind up so
you can make that rocket boost and
belong in the point I'm gonna throw a
name out there that is completely on the
opposite spectrum okay somebody that's
improved despite age coming to him yeah
and that's linear Domingues Wow agreed
he's become a top 10 player yeah he's
become a solid top two he's been top 10
right quietly right for the last few
rating lists yeah I I've always referred
to
America's bevy of talent as the Trinity
the Holy Trinity we have it but now it's
like the four men in the apocalypse but
our Olympiad team strives every linear
which we're hoping there is an Olympian
exactly exactly well I mean you're
absolutely right I mean he's gotten a
second wind oh wow his career I mean if
he wants some inspiration that can I
become world champion after this look at
linear spent a couple of years not
traveling not playing as he transfer
transfer transfer from Cuba he's put the
smack down a lot of people recently he's
crossed 2750 his health is is reigning
up there despite playing many
tournaments he went to the Russian
League and destroyed the tournament it's
really shown he's up there right now and
not only that went through the US
Championship one of the things that I
really admired about his was consistency
very strong blunders handing these guys
points not at all people just because
they get old um it doesn't mean they
just stop playing chess they get
straighter great great call breaking
news Marissa
well the near is an example of what I
was talking about the beginning of the
tournament the people who win have to
have hunger and form and when you have
been playing chess for a couple of years
you're hungry you're hungry you don't
want to go in there with a hungry lion
and he has shown that he wants to win
and his form has been excellent but I
need you guys to remind me of a quote we
recently heard I think I think it was
Nakamura but I'm not sure is one of the
top player has said that this generation
has forgotten how to play attacking
chess was it not who said that Wow
somebody yes sir I think he said it
while he was sitting in the chair with
me interviewing him this generates
because the defensive skills are so good
now and the computer is so has taught
them so well how to defend that they no
longer have their attacking chess skills
as sharp as it used to be I'm pretty
sure it was Nakamura I might be wrong
remember but I know I heard the quote I
know
the quote and you know naka says it a
little stuff but his point is you know
you don't really win with attacking
chess so much anymore because these guys
are such great defenders so that said
Geary is not known as the most
flamboyant attacker you've ever seen in
your life and in this position you see
b5 on the border you're thinking rook f1
you thinking Queen B 2 along the long
side you know you're thinking some
pressure move and Geary
his style said I'm gonna apply a quiet
one I'm gonna play R okay - okay H - I'm
gonna guard this square so my Queen can
move now the Angels had all the moves
completely eviscerating black queen bee
- was a starter your instinct yeah sir
you said queen bee - lets go for it this
one it says well he's still definitely
better but you're giving him a free move
rook e8 he's gonna start consolidating a
bit more although he's still worse even
the move h5 was quite strong the
response rook h5 came on the board this
this kills a try for sure and now it's
back to Geary needs to think about this
position you know pieces are gonna come
as you mentioned alejandra he wants to
start protecting his King he wants to
bring a rook over he gets his queen on
d6 he wants to just put everybody all
hands on deck the king is in trouble
we need to harmonize so here we can't
just keep playing quiet move after quiet
mo have to quiet move because box gonna
consolidate eventually and this moved by
the way also hits the bishop so you
can't move with your queen c6 you know
you you guarded your part but now your
Queen's not released because the bishop
is hanging for the moment so blacks
gonna get a couple of have a question
for the engine yes is rook F to work
everyone not just when you walk work f2
is definitely a very strong move and
according to the age of the best move in
the position so good luck
Black is still in trouble don't get me
wrong like I still in trouble and
stylistically this fits Geary yes again
he's not gonna be flamboyant he's not
gonna be sacrificing all those line oh
if it comes yes he'll do that but he's
the kind of guy was like Karpov I'll
suppress whatever dreams you have any
fantasies I'm gonna make it very clear
to you that you're still asleep stay
asleep and I'm just gonna build and
crush you probably still in a lot of
trouble in this position
like jump in and say we've got a caller
this time from Israel overseas
hello Israel your name and your question
please
oh hello my name is Jonathan I'm from
Israel and first of all I really really
appreciate you guys your show and your
comment and really enjoying it and I
wanted to ask if you prefer these this
kind of set up were candidates for the
for the world champion is decided to a
tournament rather than through
candidates matches like Fischer had to
play against Petrosyan and against
others right well thank you for the
question Jonathan quite definitely we've
been talking about the history and the
cycles over the course of time so if you
go back to the end of World War two and
the fact is that they had these
candidate tournaments to find the
Challenger in this case too bad Vinick
and they kept that system more or less
until Bobby Fischer made the great
complaint that the Soviets are colluding
in the tournament against me they're
cheating and to stop that collusion then
they went to the matches after the fall
of the Soviet Union looked around and
said you know that those candidates
tournaments were really pretty good
events and furthermore it's kind of hard
to organize all of these matches these
match play made made the cycle like
three years very long right exactly
so there's historical reasons there's
financial reasons economic reasons I
personally I have to say I love match
play I love it too I really do I really
do but having said that once I saw that
2013 London tournament that was one of
the most exciting tournament events I've
ever seen in my life and I became a big
fan
of the tournament sorry the system yeah
I like both I'm on the fence I like both
I really like knockouts I don't like
those matches where it's just so
difficult to organized one here one
there didn't like that system where it
was just kind of spread out it didn't
cohesive okay I like that right now we
have the candidates and boom some
various well we'll come out ahead
now if this was a match format I
wouldn't mind that either for example
the way the Grand Prix system works
where you have this matches and it's a
knockout mini matches if you will right
maybe you can have them a little bit
longer because it is the candidates
favorite for six rounds per match for
games you still only have three rounds
anyway total amount of matches so it
could be doable I would be open to other
ideas but I like this system right I
don't like the system so much that the
world champion is just waiting at the
end exactly that is the part that I
don't like I know magnums himself
doesn't like mentioned that it's a bit
unfair towards his components he's even
proposed to knockout system which I
thought was a bit extreme but it's the
idea has been thrown out there I don't
know I don't have a strong opinion I
think every system has flossed but this
was pretty cool okay all things
considered maurice jump in breaking news
breaking oh I see you got the Wang Hao a
NAPA game up on your board Maurice yes
indeed and it looks as though jana
novotná Qi is winning the game winning
c5 was played by yarn after the King
marched into the position and now Knight
to b5 Queen b8 check acquit excuse me
threatening Queen b7 with check and in
this position
there were defenses Knight takes d4 is
one Queen a seven is one one that is not
a defense however is the move Queen d7
looks very natural regards to pawn and
attack this pawn the problem is the move
Queen h8 is extraordinarily powerful now
he might feel like this move that looks
reasonable that'll save me yeah the
problem is the wild f4 f4 now therefore
of course it's threatening me
all right that's a pond that's hanging
so you would think well what if I take
this part now this is this is gonna be
really sharp to calculate obviously
night takes we toss in a queen g8 with
check nothing else to do you don't want
to hang this pawn King g7 give me the
pawn trade Queens push pawn to easy
so after this move you must no other
choice
block with the Queen and now look at
this nasty move Queen to d8 hitting the
night we got a Queen d6 mate on tap
watch out how do you defend everything
now Queen d7 that does guard everything
except now you can play the move f5
takes on f5 takes one in five and you
can't guard your queen you've got to
play Knight takes Queen takes King takes
and that's gonna be all she wrote
now all those moves we're not totally
easy but there is indeed a win there and
we do have with us one and maxime
vascular grove say hello Maxime in
Yekaterinburg yes hello thank you for
joining us what a game you had today
what a treat you gave us tell us about
it where did it start where did it and
when did you start thinking actually in
this game well I did start to think I
mean there there were some times where I
was not gonna have to think at all but
he will avoid it the most obvious draws
and so at some point I got like
compelled to to think about it and to
see whether whether I had to win
somewhere and but I don't think that
ever was a case so he will took his time
but I think he played reasonably well
reasonably well it was such a
complicated position it seems both of
you were finding such extraordinary
resources especially for him we felt he
gave you a blow room takes physics
instantly rook takes c3 Knight takes c6
is the new queen say that must be so
unpleasant as a player facing such a
well-prepared player in such a sharp
line yeah but the thing is I wouldn't
pick g6
unless
I was prepared for actually the most
obvious continuation so once I I mean
the surprise frame was that I could play
g6 but once I did you realize that you
know I I must have done my own work you
certainly did and even though you did in
fact show that your homework was really
really good we were excited by this
extraordinarily sharp game well for you
with the key critical moments after the
sacrifice Maxine I think okay well page
six is a critical try for white take
take Roxy to and she I thought if where
it wants to go have a chance you have to
go to xt6 sorry 166 at once I see and
how did you anticipate the game
continuing after rook takes d6 well I
knew this should find for me and I was
looking forward to spending my one and
there are power to figure out what to do
I think I think night a4 is natural but
then maybe ugly to I mean at least it is
playable Hawaii it should be should be
stripped and orange equal I would say so
you so for you rook takes d6 was a
critical moment I thought so
or like night at five qingyi eight whole
text e6 of course she's also possible
yeah and I think the point is if you go
Knight a for here with black again 97
Kim G eight also I could play king of
fate of course about the 727 in King C
to Quincy six check nice nice yeah and
it's just the purpose well some
compensation but yeah nice line varies
yeah Maurice you want to jump in yeah
yes absolutely amazing game have you had
a chance to look at the other games it
looks like neppo has indeed found Queen
h8 and this looks extremely dangerous
your thoughts on net post play so far as
he could take the lead now and be ahead
in the tournament yeah it's been
impressive so far I mean but his nipple
so like it will always play fast and
sometimes he should have gotten punished
for it so you know it's only the
beginning of the tournament e he worked
up some points but yeah in this game
against Sasha was very strange so you
never know what before what can happen
with him yeah my knots and I do know
this line quite well about that we had
this wonderful when we found for you
with Ramanujan yes were you able to
consider it maybe we can pull off the
game maybe pass we had the game
yesterday I'm sure somebody told you
about rookie foreign taking on c4 no of
course the thing is during the game I
just didn't see that hooky who was
threatening would take sequel and the
reason why is I was considering this
line where you attack the bishop but
that was mostly considering hooker for
example can bring it up on maurices
board so we can follow I don't know if
you can I takes you were saying after
nine takes a for you had you were
thinking what rook F for is what yeah I
mean if I wanted to attack the pieces I
wanted to look at four to like some
Bishop e6 and then of course you can go
b5 you avoid Bishop e6 but yeah because
I won't be here you don't have her take
C also consider working for but I did I
didn't realize that I was stretching you
texaco
and that was when I played a four and
also instead of 34 I first wanted Bishop
e3 I mean I have to mention this 9 and
then Knight f4 is
I would like but I was worried about 97
yeah and then it turns out that I missed
this is six Bishop e6 and now I let you
finish sir Chuck in their education d4
with rook f7 Bishop c4 you're attacking
g7 your threat floor is just before
exist I think before Knight f6 is fine
for black but mo is the engine clear the
cobwebs the beautiful rook takes Bishop
takes you can't go to f6 it's done every
day you see a gorgeous mate like that
one that's not that's really nasty and
of course you know here then gives us
this guy the whole thing collapses
online thanks for sharing that one with
us Wow so it somewhere you would have
won the brilliancy there such I would
have been 97 or 98 oh right he was under
severe time pressure by ask you yes in
this position here when you did play a
four and he took wait were you just very
clear that you wanted to play Bishop a3
like your pawn was a four to play Bishop
b3 so exactly rookie for just wasn't
really on the agenda yeah exactly
okay for was nothing and yeah and I saw
this position after will take c5 and I
thought I was still slightly pressing
and and I didn't find any other way to
to punish his play yeah that's what I
suspected that once we get our minds a
certain way it's very hard to this
switch and go back in the other
direction but definitely fantastic
Anthony E from this a5 idea and
don't think I have anything indeed very
very difficult before we let you go your
thoughts about how fabi's doing against
giri it look like he may have made some
mistakes there he's mighty back well I
mean his position was very suspicious
from the start I thought right and yeah
I don't know how things completely
transpired but of course this position
is very difficult I mean it doesn't look
as bad as it did before that but still
probably pretty dangerous but I might be
wrong what's wrong with 93 if we could
just like some there's some tactics
suddenly witchdoctors rook c8 i'll take
a high 27 as long as I have the darks
course I'm gonna make an argument then
right well she might is anchored yeah
hoax you want after King g7 so we're
looking at something like this and
Maxine is offering new rook c1 c1 and by
the way we're still Knight d5 keep on
check probably with an IC 193 I guess I
have to go back yes and then I have all
the luxuries or to find a good move but
at the same time your king is someone
under control so it's very possible that
this is okay for block no that's the
first good news we've got him for Fabia
all day indeed it is
before we let you go your thoughts
overall about the players who in your
mind has distinguished themselves you're
comfortable with your score you've been
tied for first just your overall
perceptions of the candidates thus far
I'm comfortable with the way I played so
far in general with the way of some my
preparation held up it's on because of
course that was a question mark
before the tournament started but you
know I have good workers
they're happy to hear you say that
you'll blame them if anything goes wrong
yeah but they'll ask for a race what the
last four races have to be careful
they'll ask for more money there's much
in Dubai but very nice imagine Dubai
okay Maxie thank you so much for joining
us it's been our pleasure thank you
bye-bye for now as we get ready for our
first plate just tell us Marissa is nepo
about to go +2
indeed it does look as a plus two is on
the way queen of seven has been played
he's been thinking for some time here in
this position he does have two options
Queen d8 or queen c8 it's nice when you
got two but either one this really is
compelling
the next move because this King has
nowhere to go and the threat is f5 when
they say and between d6 and Queen are
hovering all these are settling in and
if you play the move Queen d7 as we
mentioned probably actually funny the
key engines don't want to repeat Italy
check and then go back and then play a5
very much we're sure to see that line
torture from the from the engine but
taste takes Knight takes obviously force
that's the band's thank you very much
for a piece you can go home the other
line here after Queen Queen d8
night-night b5 is also playable and now
this suggests this move you no longer
have this response as f5 will come at
you very quickly takes takes your king
has to back up and look at this win
Queen back with your king Oh totally
travel captures is happening
check pawns go to Queen you're gonna get
crushed in this line as well so we have
that you want to play you want to play
some moves yeah Queen d4 not really
because I feel that what I just
explained the line so we go down this
position
Queen Queen I wanted to put the King on
d70 King to d7 and now more marching
towards your King sooner or later the
Queen's gonna get on e6 well maybe you
could even go to e6 with that one right
well we've been talking about how nice
at the pawn on h6 is to have so that you
can checkmate on g7 but I know we want
to go into break but really quickly what
is your karana because the moves that
Maxine was wrecked we're recommending
are on the board
rooks even already played there is a
deadly threat of rooks e7 check
knee-jerk reaction was to the
threatening Knight c3 it's offense and
defensive well that Nakamura quote comes
back is it and I'm if it's not naka let
me know please akaru if you hear this
but I think it was I think it was him
saying it to me about the attacking
skills of this generation he has thrown
away all his advantage very literally
went from devastating crushing attack
you move that position you said let's
play rook F - yeah well rook h2 said
rook h2 we thought okay but work if ii
was really strong still he played rook e
to understand why why do you want the
roof of the ephah i wanted to hit the
night i wanted a queen bee - i want to
direct attack kill the king another
waiting move Allah Allah Fabi from the
Diggler endgame like an eight-six he's
awesome yeah this one rookie - was also
saw he gave the d5 square to the night
and then the night what a nice blue
nighty Knight g4 such a nice move
hitting the rook and thanks for the
tempo good let's trade off a pair of
rooks like I wanted to and now rooks e1
and all Fabi has to do now is find this
very nice move I say all he has to do he
only has five minutes and change to play
but he has two more moves only two not
something so not
so bad he is fine finally in this
position this could have been an
absolute unmitigated disaster but not
going to happen and it looks like what
he did is he put his on the spot and
said look I leave it to you and we were
struggling a bit because even so yeah I
think you were the first to spot there
should be guys we're gonna get to a
break don't counts corner okay Rhonda
break that's what I was going to say
that's what we're gonna do and we'll see
on the other side of the break
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the counts
corner we have some amazing match is
going on in today's round of course we
have the tactical slugfest between Alexa
Inco and max in vascular graph which
most likely is going to end up in a
perpetual and of course we have the very
tense affair between unleash kiri and
the Fabiano Caruana but another game
that caught my attention was the one
between Griff shook and ding because
there has been some very interesting
discussion going on especially in the
opening phase of this game and let's
dive straight into that grease Chuck has
been very successful all the way up
until 2017 against ding he has bitten
him quite a few times and especially
with the opening moves of d4 or Knight
f3 with E for he hasn't been as
successful it's actually it was ding who
won one of their encounters in the same
opening that we are seeing today being
played on the board so II for a 5 9 12 3
Knight to c6 Bishop to b5 a6 Bishop to a
four-night 12 6 Castle Bishop to e7 and
we have seen this game already being
played three times in the database
between these two guys and of course one
of them today and in previous encounters
we have seen Greece should choose this
variation as well with the move d3
defending the pawn on e4 with the pawn
and this kind of asks blacks black
question is it going to go d6 or is it
going to continue with b5 the problem is
you cannot go Castle because then most
likely you can even lose upon with
Bishop to c6 you take Knight takes e5
and the pawn on e4 is protected so of
course you have to protect this pawn on
e5 somehow you have the option of
playing d6 like I've said or defy b5 was
played in their encounter Bishop to b3
d6a for and this is the very important
discussion that I want to have with you
guys this type of structure I want to
understand before a5 and we will see
there's a big difference between this
game which was played a couple of years
ago and the game that we are seeing
today between these two gentlemen Castle
Bishop to e3 h6 Knight to Knight bTW to
rook to e8 c3 Bishop to f8 h 3 and now
we will understand the biggest
difference between the structure that we
have today and this structure with an
early a4 b4 and immediately a5 trying to
stabilize a weakness on a6 the problem
is that this point on a5 despite the
fact that it's taking a lot of space for
white is gaining a lot of space for
white it could also become a liability
in the future and this is exactly what
Bing has done he played a move rook to
b8 route to e1 b takes c3 bit a c3 and
now the bishop with a bishop on c8 ready
to jump to e6 and try to challenge the
bishop on b3 and with the open file this
is a completely different position that
what we're seeing today this route b5
maneuver is very important in this
structure and with the bishop on b7
black is not going to have it as easy
and this bishop is most likely going to
be stuck to the defense of the pawn on
a6 but right now after d5 Queen c2
immediately unable to challenge this
light square bishop on the g8 a2
diagonal and the rook is ready to jump
to b5 and we've seen ding being very
very successful with this approach let's
go back a few moves because we have seen
another game so in today's game instead
of d3 we are saying we should play the
move rook to e1 defending the pawn with
the rook and keeping the option of d4 in
one move alive b5 Bishop to b3
castle and now
in a previous game we've seen Greece
should play the know not to move h3 we
have seen Greece should play the move h3
today in a previous game we have seen
Greece to play the move a for once again
striving for this structure a5 the
problem is once again the bishop is on
c8 is not yet ready developed on b7 and
after d3 Bishop e6 immediately
challenging once again the bishop on the
light squares and black didn't have any
problems in that game either rook to b8
route to b5 came and the pawn on e5
became a weakness and it seems like
Greece shook is trying to avoid this
type of structures at all costs so today
we have seen Greece to take a completely
different approach play the move h3 of
course the main line is c3 the problem
with c3 is that you're going to allow
the marshal and King has been playing
the marshal not very successfully
especially in his last two games in the
last one he lost against raja baath in
the world cup he also lost last year
against Magnus Carlsen so I was
expecting Greece Chuck to see him
capitalize try to capitalize on this
apparent weakness in dings repertoire
but he decided to avoid the marshal and
he played this move h3 now the problem
is if you go d5 as black I'm just simply
going to take you're going to take I'm
going to capture the pawn and you did
the fact that I don't have the pawn on
Syria I'm going to be able to
immediately get the knight out via c3
this is just a much better version of of
the marshal and is considered not to be
a sound sacrifice for black for this
reason Black has a couple of other
options he and played d6 the problem
with d6 is that I'm just simply going to
go c3 and right now I'm getting what I
want I'm getting the main line of the
real Lopez but without giving you the
option of entering the marshal so pink
decided to play the move Bishop to b7
and right now we're starting to
understand the big difference
between what we have seen before in the
encounters between these two players and
what we are seeing today
Bishop to be 7d three the five take 95
tonight BT to Queen to d7 a4 and once
again we see this structure but
fortunately for white after b5 before a5
the rook will have a very difficult task
reaching b5 the bishop on b7 is not
perfectly placed despite the fact that
it's set on a very nice diagonal the
problem is there's a lot of pieces in
its way and there's not a lot of targets
this Bishop Bishop is actually a much
better defensive strategically defensive
piece we are c8 to e6 to try to
challenge the light square bishop on
this diagonal unfortunately he's a long
way from there and wishbone b7 is just
simply not a very good piece as white
I'm going to put the bishop on c4 then
jump with an item b3 solidify this
weakness on a6 I'm just having a much
much better strategical position and
this is exactly what we have seen from
Greece shook we're seeing him being
quite successful in today's game he has
a very annoying pressure let's see if
ding is going to be able to save this
game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back it is the fifth round but
we have breaking news with Maurice
Ashley indeed we do and this is going to
be absolutely monumental huge for the
tournament as Queen see a Czech Queen d7
he said now let's repeat like a cat
playing with a mouse Queen to d8 that's
the killer blow with the threat of Queen
a d6 made on the table f5 check takes
takes no choice here and now Knight
takes on f5 and it is his move is neppo
we expect to see the move Queen takes d7
King takes and Knight takes and this
ending King e6 could be play Knight to
III is what we project as the best move
this is just busted this is just
straightforward bust you got two
problems the knight can either hit on b7
or can hit on h7 you got two weaknesses
that if you go one way he's going the
other way and it's just too fast in the
meantime the King will march into the
game and prove to you that you have zero
play these pawns are just horrible this
backward be pawn will be the death of
him and we actually do have the position
on the board after King to e6 we expect
this killer retreat of 93 and with this
win nepo will go to +2 and take over so
lead in the tournament other players
will have to get e up so they can try to
stay in range because we know in these
tournaments when someone gets hot they
can be very hard to catch well this is
the current standings Maxine washer
allograft currently the leader with
three points we are expecting that he
will be leapfrog by Jana Parvati who
will reach three and a half out of five
Wang Hao will stay at two and a half
though as we expect that a game to end
in a draw and that will give us a first
the first clear leader of the candidates
of 2020 will be Jonathan yashi after two
victories saving that game yesterday we
can say was a safe against Fabiano
Caruana well I'm still thinking of the
Grantchester in Zagreb where Yann
started really really hot three out of
three and Gary Kasparov Wan Gary
Kasparov asked the question as he played
Magnus yet yeah there's no Magnus in
this tournament
there's no madness but it wasn't John
Magnus that netball lost against ya in
the grand chester he ended up on a +3
after the first half of the event right
that I'm actually a minus 3 on the
second half to finish a 50% if I
remember correctly so III got a corner
he did in the second half but talk about
yon for a second force Maurice how do
you rate his chances it's nice to be in
clear first
it's absolutely nice to be in clear
first and I don't think it's fair to
just talk about Zagreb Yanis show that
he can win big time tournaments alright
big big dog tournaments and he has
played the move Knight to e3 this
position is virtually resigns now let
like resign and it looks like the game
is over wang hao has resigned
Napo is now in clear first he has won
heavy duty tournaments against elite
players and he has proven time and time
again that he can do so there's no
question that he is one of the favorites
and the fact that he's now +2 Fabi is
sitting on 50% ding Lorraine is going to
be sitting on minus 1 those are the two
players in the tournament higher rater
than he is that means to me his destiny
is really in his hands he if he could
just keep a couple he just needs a
couple more if he goes to +4
I mean who's gonna who's gonna do that
somebody's gonna have to catch fire to
get to him so right now after five
rounds with nine rounds to go he's just
gonna bide his time and if he can get a
couple more that's gonna be a big time
number now get I got you it's not easy
to do he has shown instability in the
past but today's the candidates and I
tell you hunger and form and a little
bit of luck he saved that game against
Bobby those are usually the signs of
somebody who could win the tournament I
do have a question because I am blanking
out and at the moment I'm sure that you
guys will come up with the answer
quickly but which round robin has nipple
one I can say but he actually lost in
the last round - OH - Wesley Wesley one
that vikon's a not not a round robin but
of course him jerusalem you won the
grand prix
really important to him and he defeated
mvo also on the way for the fade away ye
in the finals
exactly it claimed that one which he
needed to get to the cabinet precisely I
mean everything had to work out
perfectly I just want to make a quick
point here that I would be furious with
myself Wang Hao losing this specific
position this ending to all the world
that looked to me like this was even but
after the move h6 followed by c4 this is
where neppo found found like every move
was just it was every way every single
move putting pressure yeah we're here h6
their queen h2 here's now agonal on the
king here's another piece of the puzzle
this is another good one
metric it is it was a beautiful
completion of a game I I never saw but
once she saw this move Queen h8 you knew
who had the initiative Queen d7 was a
mistake but yeah you need a mistake in
order to win it
Cheska absolute and if you're putting
your pressure on your opponent if you're
saying move after move the guy's got to
find a move exactly yeah mistake
actually prompted it with pressure yeah
it's not the mistake came out of nowhere
it's a Nepalese making good moves he's
putting pressure he was putting pressure
there and that's what you're trying to
do you crack your opponent under
pressure well how was not able to
withstand it and here we are
exactly Bravo for Yanis yeah Russia must
be thrilled oh man they're doing
cartwheels remember what our hottie
which the feed a president they use them
they're like are we gonna they ended up
with but it was touch-and-go about six
seven months ago
who who was gonna represent and there is
young and Yan by the way round one
played a masterpiece we all agree the
Mastiff who is our nation against Giri
yeah that's one of the best games that's
exact the way that he controlled the
situation is masterfully in the endgame
the prep dealing with living terrain
show prep coming at you like just
snowballs landing from out the sky and
for him to be able to handle all that
keep his equanimity is focused and then
come back with blows remember that move
be five just out of nowhere saying no
I'm not just sitting there taking your
preparation I'm gonna push and then the
beautiful technical end game that he
played that was indeed a masterpiece and
now this one I might say Karpov Ian in
nature not too much of anything might
look equal how but how about this move
how about that move defense from
multiple angles
he has played two incredible games so
far as far as I'm concerned he is the
class of the tournament at the moment
was easy to say he's also got the best
score so that's easy to say but he's not
doing it by accident he's doing it with
good play and yes he did a couple of
things we look at and say well that that
didn't look quite right but we know you
also have to be lucky in these
tournaments you can't just play perfect
chess for 14 rounds you can you can
point to every body who's won this
before maybe I nod might have said well
I didn't lose any games I was plus three
without loss in my candidates but
usually you lose on the way so for our
netball looking very good well I just
also boldly point out the obvious a
couple of years ago the world champion
wanted to work with Yana and had him as
a coach second somebody he respected a
great deal Oh young the way that he
inject creativity to a lot of positions
is really really outstanding he when he
works hard he finds unbelievable
resources out of the green field theory
nowadays revolves around his ideas he's
also a very experienced neither player
and you see the work and passion that he
puts into the game of chess and he's so
resourceful I see him playing excuse me
I see him playing blitz a lot and it's
sort of like he's very creative and he
comes up with he's kind of a kinetic
calculator just it's an impressive
yeah even even at this level he plays so
fast that he puts pressure in his
opponents and he's not afraid to get
into these complications and say I
played so fast maybe I'm not in the
greatest position but guess what you
have three minutes
you have to figure out the moves and
he's won a lot of games I can't strum
grandmasters like that I remember in the
World Cup he was playing a game where he
was just busted like totally busted
okay plates so faster than some moment
is a party house one moved at once and
everything else loses and just his
opponent with didn't have the time I
wasn't able to calculate properly chose
the wrong move in that point ended up
winning and advancing further in the
World Cup he did that similarity Incans
in Croatia against Fabi questionable
game sure sure but fast fast fast and it
would came down to it if I would didn't
he slipped and slipped and slipped and
then Apple came back in one right and
it's a very practical style combined
with a lot of work in chess a lot of
fresh ideas and it gives sometimes some
great results what happens sometimes it
backfires and we see that a lot I see
him get despawned at at time yeah I
easily depressed I maybe that's the
wrong word but he gets thrown off the
game I remembered him here in the Cinco
Cup feeling like oh my god my
tournaments over I gotta get out of here
nothing's going my way I want to go home
the first one he wins yeah whatever you
know the guy the guy made a mistake so
what the guy is not the usual bird let's
put it that way
exactly quite an unusual character Scott
his personality but there's no doubt
about it amazingly talented definitely
an amazing chess player and by the way
let's ask this question what would
happen if he won what are you what do
you rate as his chances against Magnus
Carlsen and as you know he used to have
a plus score on Magnus one of the few
players in the world who did any stuff
as a +4 in fact yes that's a plus scores
to one is is this chance of reading a
Magnus Carlsen
could it be Russia's next hope we'll see
well hold that thought and turn to the
game of an Asian fabbi it's on your
board Maurice well it's been officially
a draw for all my game is over because
it was a surreal
with Rick see one rookie one checking
came fries no worries the end of that
game any other and there we go laying
afterwards Brooksie one yeah I see five
well it's easy to see because they're
just bouncing back and forth but did he
have a way of perhaps there was a
loading there was nothing there was zero
it was this it was this ninety three
check threat it's just too much
probably found just what he needed to
find and his opponent
just let those those couple of waffle
moves if you will just man not
aggressive enough when he had a
fantastic position I think he thought
his position was so good he could do
anything right I think that's what he
was thinking like this is great I'll
just do this I'll just do this whatever
stopped his play why do I have to work
it's hard to win at this level and I'm
sure he's kicking himself right now for
what was an immense position that he
definitely should have won me at some
point he was above a piece edge
according to the engines just within
three points yes more than three points
and you're you guys had instinctive
moves your first thoughts were the best
moves Queen B - yeah so you said that's
a that looks great to me said yeah of
course between b2 definitely strong
Alejandro you said rook f2 and I'm gonna
go back to the critical moment right
there right here move yeah Queen B -
yeah so you said Ron is just like would
be to hear engine says crushing
definitely people I Brooke h2 rook h5
Alejandra you said well double up why
don't you just go f2 here and double on
the ephod and just says yeah sure just
double on the air file the game is over
he played a rook to e2 and that made his
advantage drop because when d4 happened
suddenly the knight had a path into the
game when he didn't have that before and
here you have to start being very
precise the best move is Bishop to e4
still keeping the advantage keeping this
knight from getting anywhere in the game
you need it to play this instead he
messed up he played rook to e5 I think
he thought this was stopping it
overlooked Knight g4 shocker of shockers
can't take because your rooks hanging
and then when he made one tempo loss the
night just dance and prance found an
anchor square and that was his attack
gone wow so this this will certainly be
a leave a bitter taste in his mouth that
he didn't win this game and Fabio of
course it's his whoosh I'm still a copy
%
and still 50% said Viviano Leandra
that's an early tournament still only
five rounds so normally that's the
halfway point here we're just above the
third I know is 14 rounded they're comin
left we do have a leader three and a
half points for Jana komyatti Maxine by
Charlotte graph now in second place with
+1 on three points one now he moves down
to 50% as well I mean that game against
you really should've won this game
against Ngapuhi really shouldn't have
lost in my opinion a little bit of
pressure but if you want to be the
challenge you got to hold those
positions no question of anaconda
getting himself a bit lucky today
unlucky yesterday he is currently at 50%
after beating clearly Alex and Quinn
losing to ding Lauren Alessandra Chris
Chuck is currently still playing
anything liver and himself we expect
that to end in a draw which would put
him on 50% with five draws here Alex
sank on your skier and England would
then be all tied for last with minus one
but while we wait for the result of the
game of Grichuk and England which we do
really expect that yeah we have phone
call from Maryland hello Marilyn welcome
to our show tell us your name and your
question hi my name is Amir calling from
Maryland and a great show as usual I
love the energy did you guys put into
the show my my kitties
I'm a fan of public scene with Sharla
Graz and usually he doesn't shy away
from main line openings like the Berlin
or the Marshall my friends and I would
play a type of chest called the Centaur
chest which means that we were using a
computer to help us find that moves and
when I play against a Marshall the
Marshall attacks even even computers
even engines like Houdini and starfish
they just can't find anything against it
much so my question is should the
Marshall be avoided at all cost
really question and I will say that if
you find something don't tell anybody
we will definitely give you a sum amount
of money that is a sellable secret
nobody has found anything against the
marshal for the last 30 years
exactly Kasparov himself never played
into the marshal you try to avoid you
try to avoid it and if you see modern
treatment of a 45 that does not involve
the petrol for the Berlin there 95
percent I'm not Italian they're 95% anti
marshal well I mean just take a look at
Levon Aronian 'he's career order
ordering Lorenz I mean from very very
early in the career they adopted the
marshal gambit in the repertoire it was
their mainstay and in the case of Levon
Aronian if you came the number two
player in the world just nuts add point
a lot of times you just check out
Correspondence games yeah they've
already played the center type of chess
that you guys do just as soon as you
color described yeah yeah you have
engine half-human which is really like
95 percent this correspondence games
there are you see the marshal it's like
98% row exactly and I don't want to say
that marshal is dead
what's that say I don't want to say the
marshal is dead but for all of those
viewers out there who aren't exactly
familiar with the caller's question so
okay Bobby Fischer said e for Best Buy
test and then the answer is okay what
are you gonna do to get an advantage if
I play classically as black and I put my
pawn in the center well everybody said
the way to get an advantage is white is
you've got to play the Rui Lopez 500
year-old opening with Bishop b5 and then
black says okay well I'm gonna counter
attack you in the center castles and
I'll defend the pawn Bishop e7 rook e1
and it's
essentially for well I should I dare say
500 years
oops excuse me did the one thing I
didn't want to do right this should be
five castles Frank Marshall the great
Frank Marshall many time us champion he
had an idea here instead of playing the
standard D 76 very famously essayed his
gambit that bears his name D 75 against
the world champion Jose Raul kappa
blanka and Marshalls idea originally
this is the modern martial is with the
move c7 c6
and away you go and by the way Peter
Lake oh just so many players to dr. John
none
what Marshalls original idea and it was
not bad at all his concept was like hey
notice that all of whites pieces are on
the queenside White's King has no
defenders I'm gonna play the move Knight
f6 and the idea from a Marshalls point
of view was that with no defenders on
the kingside he went after Catholics
clean this variation and copperplate
just unbelievable defense refuted it
over the board a very famous game indeed
exactly and unfortunately because of
that result the Marshall kind of died
for a while until it was revived I see
76
so today sir so today c7 c6 and now
white has been experimenting with d2 d3
as well as the traditional d2 d4 and
there are hundreds and hundreds of
top-level Grandmaster games and white is
just hitting his head against a brick
wall yeah it doesn't seem like they've
found anything for this reason key atoms
of course how could I not mention Micky
Adams yeah and it just feels that if you
know you're marshal insider now it is
just a perfect opening for black it's
thing Lorenz main repertoire it's but
you never see him play a marshal he
doesn't get a chance it doesn't get a
chance he nobody goes into it anymore
lady three early write a play for early
they don't play this move c3 which
allows d5 exactly yeah
jump in here Murray so why did you not
play the marshal gambit well I was there
an e 45 player always but you knew that
it was giving white conniptions I knew
cuz I played white with you ain't good I
I actually allowed a marshal once in my
career and of course it ended in a draw
right
and I couldn't get anything with the
white pieces so there I just avoided it
all costs it just doesn't there's no
promise there is this nothing to play
for but then you didn't find it
attractive as black well if you play a
45 it's not like you're gonna get an
automatic knight or automatic yeah yeah
I'm sorry Marshall it's not like you're
gonna get a reuleaux pass necessarily
then you'd have to deal with Bishop c4
and and ship them and go going to a
composition and those were in my
position right so my physic I'm a
Sicilian player so I wanted to play the
Sicilian and get those unbalanced
positions opposed to my Dorf really you
knew was a reliable draw that's pretty I
mean you know white plays well can I see
the position just to know what's going
on in the grocery can we do have a lot
of moves
nothing's happen but I just wanted to
kind of yeah
what's to look at well well the the
other thing is we were saying to
ourselves way way way way back yeah if
we were ever to win the e5 pawn yes okay
what kind of position will black then be
defending he doesn't want it to be
defending a king upon endgame no that's
the only one
Bishop ending was alright rook and pawn
endgame was alright a queen and pawning
game was alright they're all it looks
like bingler into saying I can get it
rook component meaning a pawn down
that's an easy enough for me I'm not
even sure he's necessarily gonna go up
on down Oh
I can take it can't I well it's black to
move I apologize Starbucks is closed I
just want to point that I take on III
take on III rookie six all of this
already on the board and since I can
just hold on to this pawn on d5 I have
not even anything with that punk oh I
beg your pardon you take with the pawn
okay played rookie six so you just kind
of defend the pawn Ruby high routine I'm
assuming F six maybe King chief is also
good either this you have to calculate
this thing that's a very hard time yeah
also solid I there is rook F 1 right
there is a rook if one sighting I'm just
I'm not saying you play King G Phi
everything I'm up and then and then
after King g5 we signed the draw you
know peace treaty I'm gonna play
probably look did she want to avoid that
wrote g7 drew b7 played instead of
whatever okay it's keeping the king
honest well you came out without a
thread right you're right
there is no thread in it and then g6 and
kingi finally rook e8 or yeah I think
pretty much anything that doesn't
blunder every way there's a Derek e8 by
the way rook b7 rook e8 on the ball I
wanted to try to trick you with the
other laws show me this right well king
of six there is a king d5 sighting okay
and hoping you might allow the chief g5
action the barometer kind of gave the
chess arbiters kind of gave it away from
Brooklyn we're right
you know unfortunately you couldn't move
the record and then there's no trick in
fact that's what he did a step excuse me
let me just move my rook in media now
zero tricks no forever well a great day
thus far for Yong Yong right and he
takes he takes Wang Hao a co-leader out
out of the picture for now yeah but also
importantly remember the tiebreaks
remind everybody about the tiebreak
first i break is head-to-head which
means that if we get to the end of the
tournament and somehow it's one how and
the poem yeah that are at the top with a
better score against one how that will
give an epic the qualification spot
against Magnus so the first tie break is
how you did against one another the two
winners if you will yes what did they do
in their head-to-head matchup yes number
one individual results is the official
name because let's say there's three
people then it's still the individual
results between nitro oh gosh yeah well
eating your KO tournament leader that's
bet that's a double win right that's a
double win every time you beat somebody
who was a potential threat and you
talked about this before and it's
getting more and more difficult for
players to catch people right you look
at Yann
yeah I'm just sitting now at plus-2
digging lauren is sitting at minus one
that's a major difference it doesn't may
not look so big it is a point in half
it's a major difference what has to
happen
dinkler it literally has to crash and
burn and and and the other way around
oh I have to crash and burn and to go
search yeah so you might feel like
there's a lot of rounds left but you
know you we've seen this story before
guys that's how long you know you you
might feel that way I gotta say
I know a lot of things could happen but
we also know how these things normally
go yeah and normally guys we do have a
result and it was even usually the way
this works when when somebody starts
taking over and people start dropping
back there's something unusual about
chess that way the guy who's in the
league usually just stays in the lead
right so it has to happen pretty soon
you don't remember we fit the formula
was lose but lose late yeah you don't
want to lose early you want to lose late
right now nepo was saying just let me
play some more let me collect a couple
more so when I lose later if I do I will
have already gotten a nice little lead
it's a dangerous moment it is still a
lot left but we'll be at the halfway
point just before you know it two rounds
and it'll be there and so watch out
because this this is right on the edge
of danger for a few people the bubble is
there for a couple of people not for
everybody but just for a couple all
right you know we do have standings
after five rounds we do have that result
already on the board yeah upon me
actually first clear leader of the 2020
candidates three and a half points and
we are following it up by having three
that's a plus one score and then on 50%
we have one half of the owner of Corona
and Aleksandra district all of them with
two and a half out of five
drill they take on each gear and thing
we're in saying look yes it's a point a
half away from net pool but they're not
out of it they're not out of it by any
means it's still a long tournament
certainly an uphill battle for many of
them but one that they can still climb
well when we came into today's action
Alejandra there was only a one-point gap
between them and this is our schedule
going forward we'll have round six
tomorrow and then the free day so that's
the schedule three games in a row three
day three games no free day they came in
today pretty well yeah and then suddenly
okay now it's getting stretched a little
bit as neppo takes a clear lead no by
any means let's take a look at the
pairings and see what is gonna be in
store for us tomorrow crucial round who
is never playing the day of tomorrow
he'll be playing with white again
we were just talking well Maurice was
just explaining like doing Lauren's far
back if he's gonna make a move Maurice
that would be a huge move they'll also
have Alexander Grichuk with the white
pizzas against Fabiano Khurana and it's
a classic matchup remember that was Doug
gave the gate Bobby
the candidate spot last time in 2018
when they were living here Alex and Cody
playing white against I'm you're scary
meanwhile Walker will try to recover
with the white pieces against Maxine the
sherrilyn Groff who repeats ball ok well
that's a very exciting occurring for
sure
I can't wait for his bat won and Maurice
Fabiano after doing really really well
he's kind of slipped precipitously these
last few rounds I give us your final
thoughts about today and what do you
think about the tournament that's far
yes I'm starting to feel that there's a
little bit of separation with neppo and
nvl those two are looking like the stars
right now and the other players in the
next couple of rounds we're gonna see
some real real decisions getting made
how to play because you don't want a
player to start extending his lead and
you want to be in the mix because
turning it on just like that is not easy
in these events it's everybody so strong
everybody's so good that once one player
gets a lead he feels like this is hard
for all of us maybe hard for me but it's
hard for the rest of you two so will
somebody in the back catch form that
they need to be able to surge and
compete at the very top it's a delicate
time even though it's still early a lot
of tournament left to be sure nine
rounds the tension is building
absolutely fascinating moment and
tomorrow just before the rest day we
know they usually give it their all
because the rest day follows so it
should be an extremely exciting day
can't wait to see it
let's just take a look at how neppo got
to where he is
he's won his first game against I'm
Ujiri a brilliant game with the black
pieces draw against Chris Chuck that was
a strange one this route it really was
it really was we didn't pay a lot of
attention to that game but I did I know
I said later I saw some articles
Christian chances
yeah Christian did have chances in that
game it seemed very dull and I got lost
on the conference where he said I fell
asleep you know like that kind of she's
the candidate Bishop c6 could have been
played but Alex anko then against come
on again a muddy escape that's really a
better position for Fabi and how well he
actually won a nice game today yes it
was drawn I'm sure it would correct play
but he put the pressure he was never in
danger he just said I can't I come here
to put pressure if you fall apart you
fall apart and she did how I just fell
apart at some point during today's game
and he picks up the point well not only
that I always feel that these
tournaments are so demanding oh yeah
that you need a little luck and we're
seeing that he's had a little luck he
needs that to continue but if he can
keep finding the moves that he played
today I mean that's all you will feel
very very confident as the yes but he's
always he's seen this story before he
was plus three in the tournament 302
start and crashed and burned against the
elite napo's the kind of guy that says
mm okay not until the tournament's over
don't talk to me until the tournament is
over then I'll tell you how I did he's
always the skeptic but so far even with
his skepticism he's got to feel like oh
great that's not so bad
yeah as we start to close the show here
just one question for you who
work with who should we call out and say
well Buchan Plotkin is definitely his
main coach exactly is the Russian
Federation coach or former European
champion he's very famous as well on the
chess world it's one of the best coaches
out there there you go and well we're
being told that this is a good time for
prediction who's going to win the
candidates after five rounds completely
biased commentators totally well let's
be honest I came in with being the
biggest favi fan yet the world and I
want to see fab you winning so I want to
safe happy I really really do but my
head says that at this moment that MBL
is looking like the man as well I'm
gonna go with fabbi just like that I
mean that's the guy okay the guy that's
the guy who's got a playmate have you
lost today would you still have sighs
Bobby I'd be crying I know you're going
with the numbers well I'm gonna say
Magnus oh sorry he's not playing I'm
gonna say MVL I'm gonna make a bold
prediction there I think neppo is really
the favorite right now but he hasn't
shown that absolute consistency for me
to just go straight ahead and go with
him and I think right now envía looks
like he's playing the tightest chess he
did have a little bit of a hiccup in
round one against Fabi it was a small
one it wasn't even that serious actually
to tell the truth it was just yet to
defend a worse position which he did
admirably but since then I gotta say
he's looked like his preparation is
fantastic and he just needs to get a
couple of wins and I'm not all souls yet
on nepo I would have said neppo but I'm
just gonna go right now with my gut and
say mvo mmm-hmm he's already booking his
flight to Dubai by the way so that's a
present oh this one is a tough one for
me I think yan is a great chess player I
just don't see him finishing well in
many events
and it's like a 50/50 does he just
destroy the tournament from now he keeps
playing good chess finds from the
resources finishes on plus five plus six
because he's just playing that well
right or does he do the necklace thing
which is he starts really well middle of
the tournament it's so so it loses a
couple of games here and there and
doesn't finished the plus three let's
say that he needs the roller coaster
nepo it's just it's just a gamble at
this point I'm still gonna go with Fabi
because I look at the numbers and it
really depends it really depends whether
he can get his head on the game I mean
when you look at it he starts fifty
percent and three of them are black he's
there's a positive spin it's not that
bad right right he has a really bad game
today it really depends can favi find
his form yeah can he get everything
that's bothering him outside of his mind
that's the big question and something
that is going around all of the
candidates it affects all of them the
situation in the world really really is
complicated a lot of them have families
in dangerous places
there's a lot of things happening off
the board that are throwing them off
their games and to guess which one is
best suited at shutting that out that's
difficult the more this progress the
more difficult it's going to become I'm
hearing that the count himself Christian
peerless is choosing mvl I'm gonna stick
with Bobby but I almost feel like not
choosing nappa by any of us is
irresponsible I know I know I know
that's just shows biases it's terrible
yeah well everyone I we just wanted to
say that it's been a fabulous candidates
tournament it's been a respite a
wonderful distraction for me personally
I'm looking forward to it each and every
day I was a little regret when there's a
free day but I just want to say thank
you all for joining us I hope you've
enjoyed our show and well you have a
great weekend okay we can stay home
[Music]
[Music]